[Music]
[Applause]
spring and albert breer senior nfl
reporter lead content strategist for the
monday morning quarterback
the best job opening based off the
quarterback position albert where would
you start
it's easy i i i want to see if your
answer is the same as mine
are you going to say jacksonville
yeah okay like just the quarterbacks
that you know that's what we're talking
about right like the quarterback
situation in a vacuum without
considering ownership gm anything else
yeah like just the quarterback himself
yeah you've got i think a guy who's
still a generational prospect now there
are people in the nfl that don't think
as highly of him as they did a year ago
and there's some stuff that's shown up i
think you know when you look at where
trevor is after a year does he process
as fast does he see it as fast as you
thought he might have coming out of
clemson
um but the talent is still undeniable
and you've got three years left on his
rookie contract which means you're going
to be playing from ahead for the next
three years so yeah i mean i think it's
a pretty easy number one the jaguars are
the one all right who's number two
so i got the list in front of me um
i mean maybe chicago
like
it depends on what you think of justin
fields there's less of a consensus on
justin fields than there was on trevor
lawrence so
navy chicago
see it depends it's like do you really
like justin fields or do you want to
have
like a chance to
go and make take a big swing you know
because i would argue like you look at
the broncos
and like just the fact that you've got
like this
like open canvas on which to
create your own quarterback situation
and like you've got the opportunity i
think over the next
you know year or two where they've got a
lot of capital they've got cap space
they've got young talent on the roster
and i know like you know you look at it
and say okay well teddy bridgewater and
drew lock aren't who you're going to
build around but you know i look at like
the opportunity to maybe do what they
did in 2012 and take a gigantic swing on
a quarterback
as a real plus you know and and i and i
think you can make the argument too dan
they have a lot of the same things going
for them that they had in 12 like when
they had the young receivers in 12 and
decker and demarius thomas
right now they've got jerry judy kj kam
kj hamler
cortland sutton and tim patrick they've
got a good young tight end and noah fan
you know they've got some good young
pieces on the offensive line they've got
javonte williams in the backfield
they've got pieces on defense and
patrick certain
and bradley chubb the same way you
looked at it in 12 where you know it was
you know again the receivers it was guys
like julius thomas it was on defense von
miller and chris harris you know i i
think there's an attractive situation
there for a veteran quarterback so you
know i i think if you like look at the
current quarterback situation the
broncos would be towards the bottom of
the list but if you're looking at what
you can maybe make it into i think
they're way further up the list yeah i
think that's a sneaky team but you're
also playing in the afc west as well
right uh why did the giants wait an
extra day to fire joe judge
i think it was as much as anything else
um
seeing where the meetings took them
and
you know look i i do think ownerships
become a little reactionary there
they're in a very like i would say
unfamiliar spot they're used to be
seeing as like the steelers are you know
like where they're this you know this
flagship organization that doesn't
operate in a herky-jerky way that
doesn't make rash decisions
and i think for them it took them some
time to wrap their arms around the idea
of firing you know a third straight
coach after two years now consider this
dan in the 85 years before 2016 when
they hired ben mcadoo that only happened
once they'd only fired a coach after two
years once they've now done it three
times in six years so i think they want
they they had to wrap their arms around
the idea of doing that
you know and then i do think that there
is some like taking the temperature of
the room there and maybe even taking the
temperature of you know the outside and
and what it was
and and and how people on the outside
were digesting all of it and um yeah i
think you know as as recently as friday
or saturday
i think john mayer's plan was to hold on
to joe judges as coach um and i just
think the more he took the temperature
of the room the more he watched what
happened on sunday
the more he felt like
to create what was an attractive
situation for the next general manager
um and get the best guy to be his next
general manager he had to do what he
wound up doing last night yeah i was
told yesterday that the you know one of
the reasons why they probably waited
today is they took the temperature on
candidates for the gm job and you don't
want to go into that job in that market
and try to clean up that mess and then
you get leftovers as a head coach who
may not be ready for that position well
perfect example dan is like what
happened in denver right like i don't
think vic fangio did a bad job this year
yeah like no he they were fine they were
since went seven and ten
um you know if you you look at the way
now the offense wasn't great but the
defense was really good you know you saw
the development of some young players
there patrick sertan um you know like i
said you know contender for defensive
rookie of the year
but you know the minute you hire george
payton you think okay like we're
eventually going to bring in george
payton's coach
same thing you know you look at like
tennessee um they hang they hung on to
mike malarkey for those two years and
they wound up having to fire him after a
winning season because john robinson
made the decision eventually i've got to
find my own guy and it really worked out
for them they went and got they went and
got mike frable and so i think when you
like hire a new gm there's always that
idea if you're hanging on to a coach
that coach is sort of walking the green
mile
um
you know and i just think it makes for a
cleaner process if you're giving the gm
an opportunity
to pick his coach and in a competitive
market where they're going to be
competing for candidates with chicago
with minnesota
having the opportunity to hire the coach
the way the bears and vikings are going
to offer that i think helps you out too
we're talking albert breer senior nfl
reporter lead content strategist for the
monday morning quarterback
has anybody talked to boomer assistant
on how he got to the moment where he is
reading a text not maybe sure who the
text is
that aaron rodgers is going to boycott
the super bowl if the packers make it to
the super bowl
i have no idea where that came from i
mean i i would say
um you know i
like aaron's like one of those guys who
likes to watch the world burn you know
what i mean like and i actually think
for a good portion of you know the off
season from like january to july
i i think he probably kicked back and
spent a lot of that time in hawaii and
watches watched everybody obsess over
him and watch the people you know in
green bay
like squirm like people that you know i
i think you know he had obviously had
issues with whether it's brian gouda
kunst or mark murphy watched them you
know in uncomfortable positions and kind
of like relished in that
and so like i the only explanation i can
come up with is
maybe he made the offhanded comment to
somebody when he was pissed off didn't
really mean it and then i mean you know
how these guys these things work
sometimes you know dan it can turn into
a game of telephone you know where it
goes from one person to the next to the
next and all of a sudden now what might
have been a joke to begin with becomes
the truth yeah it was kind of crazy but
it it just feels like
aaron's crazy idea i mean like for how
long the guy has been
i think about like 11 years like like
like how close they've gotten to getting
back to the super bowl you remember the
crazy game in seattle um when it looked
like they were going and like how close
he's got in the last few years last year
you know like should he have run it in
did he do the right thing like that
fourth down decision like all these
different things like he's been knocking
on the door so long and
the idea that he would get there and be
like screw it i'm like fu nfl i'm going
i'm not playing
it's just
i don't know i don't believe any of that
i there's there's no shred of truth in
that now do i think like do i think like
he thinks it's funny that like you know
that that for you know 24 hours
you know that got like that got traction
i think he probably does think that's
funny like even though he gets like mad
about it like i do think he probably got
a kick out of that it's weird it feels
like he's an underdog and he's probably
going to win the mvp
and it feels like brady feels like an
underdog because he's not going to win
the mvp
and you know how great players use any
kind of motivation yeah it's rodgers has
his motivation even though he's going to
be decorated here's brady saying i had
maybe the best year of my career one of
the best and i'm 44 years of age and
we didn't get i think if they got the
number one seed that brady wins the mvp
i think it i i know the shutout against
the saints hurt him greatly yeah but
it
almost felt like whoever was going to
get home field advantage between those
two was going to win the mvp
i think that's fair and like i i think
like you look at brady and the impact
he's made on tampa like he's sort of
become the program there you know
and
like i think if you went to their
training camp the last two years you
could really see it like there are so
many tenants of
uber ideas of what brady is um that have
sort of become what the bucks are and
you look at the intensity of their
practice and i remember talking to bruce
aries and jason light about this in the
summer so like tom like created like
this atmosphere this tension on offense
that everything needs to be a certain
way and then that winds up carrying over
to the defense because they're
practicing that way you know and then
jason pierre paul on the defensive side
sort of picked up the baton and says
we're going to hold ourselves to the
standard too
it's just
like and i think he was a huge part of
that new england too to be honest with
you like like why they were that way in
new england and you even see some of the
details have slipped the last couple of
years in new england like brady creates
that and so like his value to that
franchise goes well beyond like just the
numbers he's put up or where they they
are in the standings and i think that's
what ba was getting at when he said that
the other day um and even like the
ability to bring like guys like prashar
param and cyril
grayson up and get them in position to
produce like that's something we saw a
lot of years in new england right like
the new england was always able to do
that and so i think brady's value again
like what ba was getting at goes well
beyond um and then i think with rogers
there's a great case you know knows the
daria smith for most of the year no jair
alexander he still hasn't played a game
with his left tackle david bactiari um
aaron jones was out for a time like they
have maintained their level going
through a boatload of injuries so both
guys have a great great case i mean i
think it's those two and joe burrow for
the mvp that's the way i see it
raiders still going to hire a coach even
though they made the playoffs
so like i i they have a i i can tell you
like having talked to mark davis about
this a couple times like he really
wanted to give um give rich versace a
fair shot and
um they like
if you go back like october november
december the idea was we want to give
this guy a good run at
at being able to create like what he
sees as his team and i remember mark
david saying this to me like i asked
where he stood he's like rich is the
head coach of the raiders you know
saying that in a declarative way
um and you look like they're seven and
five under him um you know he got them
turned around they won a game right
after the john gruden email fiasco and
his first game as the interim coach
they survived a one-and-five stretch in
the middle of the season they survived
um you know obviously the henry ruggs
thing has greater implications than
football but that was tough on the
locker room you know too
and they survived that
and so you know i think you have every
reason to look at rich versace and say
this guy deserves a chance to to
to to have the job full-time and if you
want to hang on to mike mayok mayok
thinks the world of him the locker room
thinks the world of him the one thing
that i think the one caveat here is sort
of the business side to this right and
building something in vegas and they had
a lot of turnover on their business side
in the summer dan um you know their
long-time president mark bodaine wound
up out
and they're still reworking what the
business side look like looks like i
still i think there was this feel in the
organization that they were going to
take a big swing and whether it was
going and landing jim harbaugh
or trying to work out some sort of coach
trade this is something i you know wrote
a couple months ago that like would they
make a swing for like a mike tomlin um i
i think
that business aspect to it and and being
able to kind of be a player on the scene
in vegas was part of the thinking before
the question is whether or not what rich
pisachia has been able to do over the
last three months is enough to supersede
what you know i think was the desire to
kind of make the splash on the scene in
vegas okay but explain this to me if
you're trading for mike tomlin i hate i
hate putting mike tomlin's name out
there because yeah because i like you
don't know if he wants exactly yeah but
but when you trade a coach
it's not like you trade a player and a
player may go i don't want to go
like mike tomlin's the head coach of the
steelers could you could you trade him
if he didn't want to go no you can't no
okay no and but no but i mean like
and you know these things are always
difficult and they have to sort of
be put in place ahead of time and
um and we haven't seen one in a long
time i think the last one was gruden
right like was it gruden from the
raiders to the bucks and obviously we
saw it happen with parcells and
belichick
um but yeah this is something that like
i had sort of been tracking for the last
two or three months
and it'd come up with sean payton
potentially with the bears and like you
said like
sean payton doesn't want to go to the
bears so
like i don't think that that like that
that's the reason that one didn't get
real traction
um
but like you think about the idea of it
right like and it sort of matches up
what happened with what happened in
college
like usc didn't go and hire like
nevada's head coach or washington
state's head coach they stole another
blue bloods head coach they stole
oklahoma's head coach same thing with
lsu lsu didn't go and hire billy napier
from louisiana they took notre dame's
head coach
and so like this idea has sort of gained
traction in nfl circles over the last
couple of months especially with the
pipeline
on the coaching side a little dry and so
like i do know that it's something a
couple teams at least have explored
and yeah i mean it would be complicated
and difficult but you know i do know
like what teams were looking at was like
okay has sean payton reached his natural
conclusion in new orleans has mike
tomlin reached his natural conclusion in
pittsburgh that doesn't mean tomlin
wants to leave pittsburgh it doesn't
mean peyton wants to leave new orleans
it's the teams are sort of trying to
think outside the box and getting
themselves to a place where it's like
could we do something that hasn't been
done in a long time
but was relatively routine in the late
90s and early odds
you have peyton manning's group and you
have john elway's group vying for
you know ownership of the denver broncos
how does how does this
how does the nfl do this with the bids
uh approving the sale of does it go to
elway's group or peyton manning's group
it's like i i
i would say this um
you know like
looking at the way that these things
have been handled i'm in my time
covering the league at least
a big piece this becomes like who the
owners want in their club and you know
generally when you look at these big
decisions that are made and it's great
to have a guy like peyton manning on
board or john elway on board but what
the league really wants
is like a billionaire who can invest
back into the league
and that's what david tepper was david
tepper has endless resources and there
were other bidders david tepper wasn't i
don't believe he was the high bidder on
the panthers
but like the league saw it as we want to
have this guy in our club this guy's
going to be able to invest back and he's
going to be a great resource in the room
when we're talking about like big
picture league matters um you know you
look at with the way the la process went
stan kroenke
like did the rams have the best case for
leaving their city no the raiders and
chargers both had better cases for
leaving their city but who was going to
be able to build something spectacular
in los angeles who was going to be able
to invest the most it would stand cronky
and so like you know i i i know what
you're saying dan like and we're all
going to kind of latch on to you know
always involved with these guys
manning's involved with those guys
i think more than more more likely than
anything else is that the the nfl is
going to be focused on whichever
billionaire is funding the whole thing
and
you know like it's like who has the
deepest pockets but i would want to keep
manning
on espn like i i think it's better for
the league that he's a broadcaster
analyst i i know that he has a bigger
picture here and wants to to be an owner
but as you're saying it's not about who
you are the name recognition it's
what what's the value you bring to this
process with the other owners here
right and
i mean manning is interesting because i
think manning does want to be involved
on the football side where elway that
ship has already sort of sailed like he
was you know willing and ready to hand
the baton off to george payton in denver
uh
manning's interesting just because i
know like when he went to
denver one of the perks for him was
like the idea of getting to see john
elway do it and you know he's always
been really interested
in like the transactions of the nfl and
the way a team is built
and so you know i
i'm with you like i think like the
league would probably look at it and say
like there's value in manning in
different areas
um and i don't think we've seen like the
full breadth of what you know manning's
like second act in the nfl is gonna be
um you know but certainly yeah like you
see like he could be a really good
broadcaster there's no question about
that or
like he could wind up being a john elway
style team builder i think both those
things are in play for him
always great to talk to you albert
thanks for joining us
all right thanks dan that's albert breer
you can become smarter you can read the
monday morning quarterback he's the
senior nfl reporter lead content
strategist